- [Grizzlies announcer:] Ball at the top.
Ja intercepts the pass. He's off!
Look at those hops. He can leap
out of the gym!
- Oh, no. It happened. I jumped too high.
- [Modern announcer:] Welcome to the arena outside of space and time,
where we have 2022
Temetrius "Ja" Morant
- [Old-school announcer:] vs. 2001
Vince "Half Man Half Amazing" Carter.
- Woaaaah.
- I gotta remember that dunk for next year.
- Wow, I gotta say: I'm a huge fan.
- Let me guess...poster on your wall?
- [Old-school announcer:] You both know why you're here.
- Because I'm the most exciting player in the league.
Jinx!
- [Modern announcer:] Rules are simple:
Game to 11, win by two.
- [Old-school announcer:] And Ja with the
acrobatic finish.
- That ain't nothing. Check this out.
- You know that's trademark infringement.
- Shooting: one of the few weak
spots in Ja's game.
- My turn.
- Holy Vinsanity, baby.
- Mouse in the house!
- Oh, watch your pockets.
- [Old-school announcer:] Ja, with that
grit-and-grind mentality.
- You know, not every play
has to be in the "Top 10."
Why not?
- [Modern announcer:] Ja with the rare defensive highlight we'll share on Insta.
- I see we playin' for real now.
- [Old-school announcer:] Vince with the poster!
- [Fan 1:] Woo!
- [Fan 2:] I feel young again!
- [Modern announcer:] Ja with the
non-fungible token.
- [Fan 1:] Dunk over a car!
- This is why I don't do dunk contests.
- [Modern announcer:] Vince racking up frequent flyer miles.
- [Old-school announcer:] Is it traveling if you take four steps in the air?
- [Fan 1:] A three?
- [Fan 2:] Boo!
- [Fan 3:] We wanna see more dunks!
- I'm more than just a dunker.
- [Old-school announcer:] Eh, Vince is just playing regular basketball now...and he misses.
- If it ain't at the rim, I don't think you got it.
- You sure?
- Lucky-ass shot.
- Oh! Rare L for Ja there.
- Now game point!
- Gettin' ready for your future as a role player?
- Maybe. But today ain't that day.
- [Old-school announcer:] Vince jumps and—
- [Modern announcer:] They just keep rising!
- [Old-school announcer:] Oh, no! It looks like Ja is starting to descend.
- [Modern announcer:] Vince wins with the clutch hang-time finish.
- I woulda had you if it wasn't for gravity.
- Sure that wasn't just the weight of expectations?
- You got jooooookes!
- [Grizzlies announcer:] Wow, Ja is back and look
how improved he is!